oh look what we have here hey on
Facebook at work it was just my my
sister got engaged and it's all our
engagement photos and exit out of there
I hope YouTube watching funny videos at
work too huh sometimes you need a break
Oh tumblr you blog didn't know that I
run a food blog OkCupid Cabo boy 11
great vacation spots to go to when you
hate your job Google search
I just ate six month old cereal is that
okay was Toy Story based off a true
story
nope treehouses comm help I just ate six
month old cereal and now I don't feel
good thought I was going to die how to
dress like Prince calm Halloween's
coming up Prince shirtless is that for
the costume mmm Photoshop picture of me
with Donald Trump hair Photoshop picture
of me kissing the Queen of England and
now a photoshopped picture of you riding
me like a pony
okay I'm sorry sir it's just we get kind
of bored here I don't want to hear it
all right this was actually kind of fun
and entertaining okay so so we're good
you're fired but that was a good time
thank you again tangel 'sin